[Musique]
autres invités politiques ce matin c'est
jean françois copé merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
maire les républicains de mener ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par pascal toujours
pascal on va commencer par ces
manifestations qui se multiplient dans
plusieurs villes de france jean françois
copé contre le racisme et les violences
policières violences policières c'est un
terme que récuse christian jacob le
président des républicains est dit que
c'est un mensonge de parler de violences
policières qu'il n'y en a pas ce que
vous êtes d'accord mais ça dépend de
quoi on parle si on parle des violences
policières aux états unis je crois que
nous sommes tous scandalisés indignés et
puis surtout on se dit qu'il va bien
falloir qu'un jour ou l'autre des états
unis grands pays grande démocratie
prenne ce sujet à bras le corps mais par
les déviants mais s'il s'agit de parler
des violences policières en france se
trouve ça profondément désolant
regrettable que personne parmi les
autorités républicaines de ce pays
celle que je parle de celles qui sont au
pouvoir au plus haut niveau ne vienne
cesser cette polémique n'a absolument
aucun sens il rappelle que mr jrad
violence non non non attendez je
voudrais vraiment que dans ce domaine y
compris dans les commentaires
médiatiques on ne revienne pas sur les
éternels caricature qu'il y ait une
absolue nécessité de poursuivre sans
relâche le combat contre toutes les
formes de racisme c'est l'adn de la
république française ce sont des
générations entières d'enfants à l'école
qui sont formés éduqués à l'idée de
combattre le racisme sous toutes ses
formes il ce combat là doit être
permanent que deuxièmement il y ait pu y
avoir dans les toutes les décennies des
dérapages des comportements
inacceptables de tel ou tel individu
dans la police il faut évidemment les
sanctionner mais en venir à comparer la
situation des états unis à celle de la
france c'est proprement inadmissible
c'est d'autant plus inadmissible que
nous avons besoin
d'une police républicaine qui respecte
parfaitement les règles ce qu'elle fait
dans son écrasante majorité que sont
toujours ou aussi souvent que cela doit
être et que la justice le constate parce
que c'est elle qui dans ce domaine doit
avoir le dernier mot et pas où tu es pas
tel ou tel commentateurs que lorsque les
faits sont constatés il soit le cas
échéant sanctionner venir comparer la
situation française à la situation
américaine est absolument inacceptable
je ne comprends pas que le président la
république le premier ministre le
ministre de l'intérieur soit silencieux
sur ces sujets alors on est à s'exprimer
rapidement emmanuel macron sur ce sujet
et j'en sais rien c'est à lui de le
décider mais je comprends pas qu'il ait
besoin qu'on le lui demande ça aurait dû
être fait tout de suite et encore une
fois il est évident que dans le même
temps doivent être condamnés tel ou tel
acte de violence s'il a lieu et s'il est
établi comme tel voilà ensuite puisque
on en est là dessus j'aimerais qu'on est
le même elles voir encore plus de sel
quand il le faut pour dire que les
violences contre les policiers dans
certains quartiers mais c'est une
réalité
effroyable effroyable oui est ce que ça
dit pas autre chose un peu de l'état du
pays
on aurait vu lors des gilet jaune une
france de délaisser qui se révolte et là
c'est plutôt celle des banlieues des
minorités finalement les revendications
sont pas si éloigné un peu chauvin
violences policières beaucoup sur le
côté social qu'est ce que ça dit de
l'état du pays non je crois qu'il faut
il faut d'abord éviter de généraliser
je voudrais qu'on fasse vraiment la
différence entre puisque vous parlez des
jeans et jaune le cri de révolte
parfaitement légitime de millions de
francs c'est d'ailleurs ce qui portait
le gilet jaune comme ceux qui n'en
portait pas face au niveau beaucoup trop
élevé des impôts et des charges qui
écrase une bonne partie de nos
compatriotes qui veulent pouvoir
travailler et gagner plus et qui nous
ont écrasées de charges et d'impôts que
beaucoup de français subissent des
inégalités et envie d'en sortir dans
tous les domaines parce qu'il ya certes
des inégalités sociales mais aussi des
inégalités géographiques qui sont
importantes
c'est évident que ça ça nécessite une
vraie politique publique mais de grâce
ne faisons surtout pas le mélange entre
ça et ce qu'est devenu aujourd'hui
ce que sont devenus aujourd'hui des
agitations de l'extrême gauche dont on
sait pertinemment que leur combat
militant est un combat qui est à la fois
anti républicain et violent et que cette
violence n'a rien à faire avec des
revendications légitimes donc je crois
que dans cette affaire-là l'ordre et
l'autorité républicaine doit vous
doivent avoir le dernier mot parce que
si ça n'est pas le cas alors nous
rentrons dans un système de cogestion
avec l'extrême gauche et malheureusement
c'est très exactement ce qui m'est
aujourd'hui la france en danger
mais ce quelqu'un aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas assez d'autorité républicaine de la
part de ce gouvernement
bof c'est enfin ça fait un certain temps
que un certain nombre d'entre nous
tirons la sonnette d'alarmé sur le fait
qu' il n'a jamais été écrit nulle part
que la démocratie que la république
avait vocation à cogérer le pays avec
les mouvements extrémistes
donc il est c'est le grand jury dans un
certain nombre de domaines lorsque
j'entends président de la république ou
un gouvernement selon les cas où un
certain ministre a crédité les thèses
qui sont aujourd'hui des thèses de
militants d'extrême gauche dont
l'objectif est de contester un certain
nombre d'institutions dont la police
républicaine
je dis il faut faire attention parce que
très vite les dérapages non mais voilà
après on va pas en passer des heures là
dessus vous avez parfaitement compris
moi je pense que dans cette affaire il
faut essayer d'être juste lorsqu'il y à
des violences commises par un policier à
un moment donné qui ne sont pas
conformes à la légalité républicaine
bien sûr ça doit être sanctionné et en
l'occurrence quand les faits sont
établis par la justice elle est bon
deuxièmement il y a ceux qui relèvent de
comportement d'une extrême violence
venu encore une fois je le répète de
mouvements d'extrême gauche qu'il faut
combattre
allez on va passer à un autre sujet
c'est le sujet du déconfinement est ce
que pour vous il faut assouplir
maintenant les règles de déconfinement
notamment dans les écoles
alors moi je voudrais vraiment ce matin
avec vous tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
parce que je crois qu'on a là on est
passé dans l'excès inverse autant
je pense comme tout le monde qu'il était
important de prendre un certain nombre
de décisions de confinement au pic de la
crise en suivant d'ailleurs les
recommandations des experts autant je ne
comprends pas alors même que les experts
scientifiques ne cessent de 10 à
notamment le comité chargé de cela qu'il
faut alléger que l'on continue de
paralyser comment le fait soit certains
secteurs entiers de l'activité soit
certaines régions je suis maire de meaux
élus franciliens
je peux vous dire que personne ne
comprend que des mesures aussi rigide
dit le dossier rigide soit imposée
jusqu'au 22 juin que pour des raisons de
prudence il l'est était un peu plus
longtemps que les autres régions je
l'entend évidemment parfaitement enfin
là les résultats sont là tous les
indicateurs négatifs sont en très forte
baisse
et je vois des situations absurdes
lorsque je dîne dans un restaurant à mot
ce fut le cas ce week-end et que je me
retrouve dans une terrasse glace et
parce qu'il fait froid et que pendant ce
temps là la salle intérieur du
restaurant évident est que nous sommes à
l'extérieur avec d'autres clients en
train de dîner assez serré finalement
ayant froid je me dis mais c'est le
monde à l'envers alors que à quelques
kilomètres dans les départements
limitrophes d'ile-de-france ce problème
ne se pose pas lorsque je vois la
lourdeur des contraintes dans les écoles
qui font qu'aujourd'hui il est très
compliqué de de pouvoir envoyer son
enfant ses enfants à l'école laquelle
écoles d'ailleurs comme vous l'avez vu
quand même beaucoup beaucoup renoncer il
faut bien le dire l'école républicaine y
compris l'école privée sous contrat je
me dis on peut pas continuer comme ça il
faut assez vite pour le maire que vous
êtes cette ouverture des écoles base oui
mais enfin mouche dès le 11 mai j'ai
pris évidemment la décision prendre
toutes les dispositions pour que les
écoles soit ouverte et elles l'ont été
dans les conditions sanitaires les plus
strictement respectées mais nous avons
une pénurie de professeurs significatifs
comme vous le savez oui alors les
budgets des collectivités son exemple
les entreprises ont du mal à redémarrer
un grand plan
est en cours et se prépare que faut-il
faire je pense que ce qui est absolument
indispensable c'est de tirer parmi les
leçons à tirer de la gestion de cette
crise
une leçon qui est membre de mon point de
vue est majeur il faut laisser les
acteurs locaux traité ce qui relève de
leur compétence
donc s'il doit y avoir un desserrement
des contraintes
elle doit être à la fois réglementaire
et elle doit être de manière ciblée
budgétaires non pas au sens où nous
demandons plus de dotations c'est pas le
sujet mais au sens où un certain nombre
de contraintes très lourdes sur la
gestion de fonctionnement doivent être
allégée au moins provisoirement je pense
à ce que les experts appellent la
contrainte dite de cahors alors ça c'est
une bonne décision d'avoir allégé c'est
l'exemple type par la contrainte de quoi
passer la limitation des dépenses 1 2%
voilà pourquoi une amante
il n'a une amende bon alors bon ce
dispositif avec quelques effets pervers
notamment parce qu'il tenait pas du tout
content des villes qui les quatre ou
cinq dernières années avaient anticipé
cela en gérant bien leurs finances il se
trouve que ce fut le cas à meaux et que
nous étions sur la même longueur mis sur
la même niveau d'égalité que des villes
qui avaient pas forcément bien géré ma
foi je mets ça de côté
mais je peux plus facilement le dire sur
la chaîne sénat où nous écoute beaucoup
de maires qu'ils comprennent ce que je
veux dire mais en revanche du point de
vue technique mais simplement il faut
absolument alléger les contraintes c'est
absolument indispensable de le faire
j'espère que l'état va en tirer un
certain nombre de conséquences
l'état qui a mis en place un plan pour
aider ces collectivités territoriales on
parle d'un plan de quatre milliards et
demi c'est une bonne chose pour vous
tout dépend la manière dont l'argent
sera gérée et utilisée mais je pense que
de façon générale il faut faire
redémarrer l'économie que les communes
les départements les régions sont
aujourd'hui les principaux donneurs
d'ordre pour la construction dans le
domaine du btp par exemple mais pas
seulement tous les services publics on
est un moteur majeur pour redresser le
pays
il est indispensable d'en faire la
priorité aujourd'hui certains
gouvernements ou ailleurs dit ça il faut
peut-être baisser les salaires pour
maintenir l'emploi il faut peut-être que
l'état continue à abonder du chômage
partiel mais sur ses tenues alors moi
j'ai une approche qui est un peu
différente je pense que il est
indispensable de préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés
mais si on veut le faire il faut parler
du salaire net pas du salaire brut
et donc il faut baisser les charges donc
je pense que
une période comme la nôtre nous devons
avoir les yeux rivés sur les indicateurs
économiques comparées entre la france et
l'allemagne et donc il est capital
capital de mettre le cap sur
l'allègement des charges pour les
entrepreneurs et pour les salariés ça
doit être un grand mouvement qui ne peut
se faire que si on fait des économies
par ailleurs et c'est ça le grand sujet
de l'avenir il faut organiser les choses
pour que notre pays puisse redémarrer à
travers ces acteurs qu'ils soient
salariés professionnels indépendants ou
entrepreneurs et c'est ça qui est en jeu
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus que d'imaginer
des baisses de salaires qui aujourd'hui
mettrait les français concernés dans des
situations de réelle précarité on voit
un ces chiffres vertigineux la récession
de la dette du déficit comment on en
sort et est-ce que le gouvernement va
pouvoir s'en sortir sans augmenter les
impôts
alors je pense que si le gouvernement
pense que la solution de sortie c'est
d'augmenter les impôts mais parce qu'il
pense qu'on est là c'est pour ça que je
vous le dis mais si par malheur ils
devaient tomber dans ce piège
alors la france va couler parce que la
france aujourd'hui un niveau d'impôt
tellement élevé beaucoup plus élevé que
la moyenne des pays européens que si on
continue encore d'augmenter les impôts
alors plus personne ne s'en sortira la
seule solution c'est de faire à la fois
ce qu'on appelle une politique de
l'offre pour stimuler la production est
aussi une politique de la demande en
baissant les charges pour de redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux salariés
et si on veut réussir à faire ça il faut
que l'état maigri il n'y a pas de
solution alors quand je dis que l'état
doit maigrir il faut pour autant qu'ils
continuent d'investir dans la santé dans
l'éducation dans la défense dans la
sécurité ce qu'on appelle le régalien
en revanche je pense qu'il faut repenser
tout le reste est que dans tout le reste
il ya un certain nombre d' aide
d'intervention par exemple pour financer
la baisse du temps de travail et
d'autres êtres qui coûtent des fortunes
et que l'état ne peut plus payer alors
morel ne sais pas qui veut allonger
créer un congé pour regarder les parents
on s'appelle mesure qui vous convient
c'est exactement ce que je redoute voilà
c'est moi je peux comprendre là on est
dans une période où il est possible
qu'un remaniement gouvernement
allons tel ou tel ministre se dit je
vais faire parler de moi comme ça on
nommera ministre d'autre chose c'est la
vie humaine n'y a pas de sujet c'est
même si je peux me permettre à ses
anciens monde enfin peu importe pour
pour avoir pris beaucoup de recul avec
tout ça je permets de vous de faire
cette petite remarque par contre sur le
fond j'ose espérer que le gouvernement
ne va pas faire ce choix
aujourd'hui nous avons à financer et
c'est autrement plus urgents la branche
de la dépendance que ça que certains
appellent le cinquième le la cinquième
branche de l'assurance maladie la
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
à savoir le financement des personnes
âgées dépendantes et des personnes qui
ont un handicap ça ça va nécessiter un
gros effort de la nation
d'où l'idée évoquée d'ailleurs par
certains de supprimer un jour férié on
en a beaucoup en france pour pour
financer cela il me semble que c'est une
cause qui le légitime parfaitement mais
la réponse ça peut pas être on va
redonner des jours de congé aux français
même si évidemment qu'il faut s'occuper
de nos aînés mais il est impossible le
pays n'a pas les moyens avec 115 % de
dette de financer une chose pareille
après la crise sanitaire la crise
économique il ya une crise sociale aussi
qui se profile dans son rapport le
défenseur des droits jacques toubon dit
que les inégalités sociales ont augmenté
durant cette crise est ce que vous
l'avez constaté et comment on fait dans
mais les inégalités sociales
malheureusement elles sont la première
conséquence de crise comme celle que
nous traversons nous venons de traverser
c'est une évidence je le confinement n'a
pas été le même pour tout le monde
il est certains bâtiments hameau dans
lequel je le sais certains de mes
administrés ont vécu dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles malgré tout
l'aide qu'on a pu essayer d'apporter on
le sait et on le voit bien
donc en réalité il faut reprendre
maintenant notre notre chemin il faut
pour ça que je disais il faut que le
gouvernement allège le plus vite
possible et contraintes pour trouver des
solutions et permettre d'accompagner
ceux qui souffrent le plus mais pour ça
il faut avoir la possibilité d'accéder à
eux sans que les contraintes soient trop
forte et tout en vous le 10 ans je
rappelle comme le fait à juste titre le
gouvernement qu'il faut absolument
respecter les gestes barrières que quand
c'est nécessaire il faut porter le
masque
c'est tout ça est indispensable et je
crois qu'on doit être capable dans une
grande nation comme la nôtre de trouver
le bon équilibre
elle est on va parler d'aidé municipale
à 20 jours maintenant
du second tour qui ne vous concerne pas
vous avez été réélu au premier tour dans
six villes six grandes villes
il y aura des listes communes entre la
république en marche et les républicains
est ce que vous comprenez ce choix ou
est ce que voulait rien et je pense
qu'il ya des fois où c'est nécessaire
moi même d'ailleurs à paris il ya
quelques années peut-être en 2017 ou 18
j'avais été interrogé sur le sujet
c'était après l'élection de monsieur
macro et j'avais préconisé qu'à paris on
fasse cela pas du tout pour gommer les
différences qui d'ailleurs sont
croissantes on le voit bien en trouver
l'air est en marche mais tout simplement
parce qu'il peut se trouver que ça se
justifie
et là en l'occurrence à paris je vois
arriver la réélection de madame hidalgo
sauf à ce que rachida dati qui fait une
campagne absolument fantastique harry va
bousculer à bousculer cela et je le
souhaite d'autant plus fortement que je
vois en tant que maire de grande
banlieue
c'est de la ville de paris se fermer de
plus en plus et empêcher son accès donc
ça c'est extrêmement préoccupant
donc c'est à dire qu apparaît donc les
alliances au delà du 5ème arrondissement
est ce que par exemple son nom mais
c'est au troisième tour vous souhaitez
des alliances entre les anciens métiers
se damner le troisième tour déjà pas sur
le deuxième c'est avec moi j'ai appris
avec mon ami guy drut faut passer une
haie après l'autre donc on va faire les
choses dans le bon ordre
en revanche de manière plus générale sur
les autres et les autres cas en fait
c'est du cas par cas on peut pas mettre
de l'être dans la même liste
bordeaux par exemple où ça beaucoup de
sens et où j'espère de tout coeur que
que notre candidat va l'emporter que
lyon où là c'est pas du tout une
alliance avec en marche si une alliance
avec gérard collomb qui étaient décidées
par les autorités
les responsables locaux de notre famille
politique moi même je suis un peu
circonspect mais enfin après tout on
verra ce qu'il en est pourquoi
circonspect bas parce que parce que il
c'est une alliance avec gérard collomb
qui est sorti quatrième donc très
contesté bon c'est à paris vous avez dit
que l'air et l'om se sont de plus en
plus éloignés donc vous êtes seront
déçus du fait que le président macro
sont peut être pas tout à fait un
président de droite
oui enfin des sujets en tout cas
j'observe qu'au fil du quinquennat là où
je faisais partie de ceux qui à droite
avait un regard bienveillant parce que
je pense que ce qui compte c'est que la
france réussit ce n'est que quand je le
voyais gouverné par donnant cependant un
certain nombre de décisions j'avais le
sentiment qu'il y avait une dynamique
forte qui pouvait être engagée
je ne la retrouve plus depuis un certain
temps et alors j'entends les ministres
d'hier on n'a jamais autant réformes et
que de toute l'histoire de la france bon
c'est classique là encore pour dire que
j'ai un petit peu d'expérience on a
toujours ce réflexe de procès que ce
qu'on fait mille fois meilleur que
excuser les autres avant et est
nullissime
mais bon je suis quand même obligé de
vous dire que je suis aujourd'hui sur ma
faim winants beaucoup de domaine louis
françois baroin dit que la droite se
reconstruit que se forme narc à gauche
vous voyez venir le retour du clivage
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où le
message de du fameux et en même temps de
d'emmanuel macron qui en clair avait
pour vocation de gommer les différences
entre la gauche modérée et la droite
modérée pour aller vite
en fait de fait ça ne marche pas parce
que du coup il c'est de l'amener à pas
choisir c'est moi je pensais que cela
mènerait à choisir et en fait ça là
plutôt amené à ne pas choisir donc
forcément les du coup la réalité
politique reprend reprend ses droits et
c'est normal de toute façon une chose
qui est certaine on peut plus continuer
d'avoir un débat politique qui
s'articule entre un parti de
gouvernement et l'extrême gauche et
l'extrême droite
il ya un moment c'est pas possible ça
devient ridicule donc il faut absolument
qu'un certain nombre de voix qui sans
être macro nist mais sans être non plus
totalement anti ma chronique puisse
s'exprimer
marquer des différences incarner une
alternance sans se faire insulter toute
la journée au motif qu'ils seraient ce
des idiots alors que les actuels sont
des intelligents mais il ya un moment il
faut quand même qu'on se détendent un
peu avec tout ça françois varin qui dit
également que la droite en termine avec
un long cycle de défaites est ce que
cette victoire qui s'annonce pour les
républicains municipale elle a forcément
sans cesse que c'est pas trop optimiste
on se rappelle en 2014 vous étiez
président du parti il y avait une vague
bleue aux municipales et en 2017 la
droite était absente d'abord merci de le
souligner un toit si fréquent qu'on
fasse le lien entre cette vague bleue
2014 et fait que j'étais en charge du
second tour en 2010 est est-ce que c'est
pas trop optimiste djellaba h un bar en
moins goûté on verra bien vous pouvez
vous pouvez quand même permettre à
françois baroin de dire qu'il se réjouit
résultats du premier tour on regarde au
regard de la descente aux enfers qu'on a
connus depuis jeudi rassurées manière
efficace puisque le oui il est réélu
absolument
simplement non ce que ce que je veux
juste vous dire c'est que le premier
tour et a montré quand même que la vague
bleue 2014 ce qui a permis à la droite
de conquérir en 2014 69% des villes de
plus de 9000 habitants
ce premier tour des municipales a été
très très encourageant et a conforté
effectivement l'ancrage de la droite
française dans les territoires bon alors
après il faut effectivement dire il faut
attendre le second tour
bien sûr et il ne faut surtout pas je
dirais polluer l'analyse qui en sera
faite par le résultat de telle ou telle
grande ville passe toujours comme ça que
ça marche on dit ah bah oui mais paris
était bloqué par la réalité du
territoire on le voit bien c'est que
maire de droite ont pris une option très
forte pour remporter le second tour dans
d'innombrables ville donc c'est
évidemment très encourageant pour nous
bien sûr françois baroin qui est qu'il
dit qu'il se donnera sa réponse à
l'automne soit une probable candidature
une éventuelle candidature en 2022 vous
l'a souhaité vous savez j'ai goûté on a
d'abord on se parle beaucoup enfin moi
je me suis un peu me en recul de tout ça
mais moi je parle évidemment beaucoup
avec l'ensemble des candidats possibles
en a un certain nombre donc on verra
bien ce qu'il en est on va déjà faire en
sorte de de voir quelle est la réalité
du paysage et puis c'est aux candidats
de ceux de se prononcer c'est pas à moi
de dire si je veux tel ou tel déjà que
l'on voit ce qu'il en est et puis le
moment venu vous pouvez donner
facilement les être un bon candidat
c'était bien un mot vous avez envie de
vous impliquer davantage au niveau
national
vous savez écouter moi j'ai encore une
fois je suis aujourd'hui très dédié à ma
responsabilité de maire de meaux par
ailleurs je suis avocat j'ai pris
beaucoup de recul avec la politique
nationale néanmoins je veux participer
au débat public du fait simplement de
l'expérience qui est la mienne et j'ai
envie de partager avec avec les français
avec celles et ceux qui qui ont qui ont
envie de réfléchir à l'avenir parce que
aujourd'hui notre pays est quand même en
proie au doute et il faut lever ce doute
absolument un dernier mot sur cette
tribune de marine le pen dans la revue
politique et parlementaire qui sort
aujourd'hui dans laquelle marine le pen
s'inscrit dans les pas du général de
gaulle qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est de la récupération à deux francs
50 parce que entre nous soit dit
on tourne la leader de l'extrême droite
expliqué que les gaullistes et que c'est
nous qui ne sommes pas c'est quand même
comment dites comment disait la chanson
d'autres fois j'ai la mémoire qui
flanche
voilà la mémoire qui flanche
pour vous c'est quoi c'est une tentative
de dédiabolisation de la part de marie
le pen ou ceux ci une volonté de
s'adresser à l'électorat de la drague
hausse mais comme d'habitude de la part
de l'extrême droite allait s'adresser
absolument à tout le monde sans aucune
espèce de nuances particulière et encore
une fois je le répète en ayant une
réalité historique
l'extrême droite a toujours été par
définition une famille politique à
l'opposé de la famille gaulliste pas
alors qu'elle veuille nous expliquer
qu'elle se retrouve beau livre c'est que
demain il va se trouver
jean jaurès aussi peut-être je sais par
23 heures à tous de vous être ne doit
laisser personne dupe
voilà merci beaucoup merci jean françois
copé